hello my name is matt
b fliggle and i am a senior manager of
the in vivo sciences group at charles
river laboratories in shrewsbury
massachusetts
and today as the title indicates i'm
going to be discussing
not just how we developed a
icv model for rodent injections
but more importantly what were the
challenges
what were the struggles and how did we
overcome them in the midst of the
coronavirus pandemic
that we are currently all dealing with
as just a brief biography i've been in
the lab animal research and surgical
field
since about 1993 i've had
the luck and frankly the
fun of working in a whole host of areas
be it cardiovascular device implantation
central nervous system pulmonary device
development
transplant etc and i've also had the
good fortune
to work with a wide variety of species
from mice
to non-human primates to livestock
i've been a supervisor and a manager in
these types of groups and departments
since 2003
and what will factor in to what we're
going to discuss for the next
25 minutes or so i've also been the
principal
surgical instructor for several hundred
surgeons and anesthetists for about the
last quarter century
along with that i am an adjunct
professor for the lab animal surgical
classes
at worcester polytechnic institute and i
have the
good fortune to manage a team
of a little bit over 70 people right now
in shrewsbury mass
technicians surgeons anesthetists
supervisors data reviewers team leaders
lab assistants and what have you
as far as the procedure that we're going
to talk today
one of the things that made it doable
is i've been doing these for a long time
i've done a lot of them
my logs aren't complete but they reflect
over ten thousand
uh of these surgical cases be they
into the cerebral ventricle area hip
campbell
device implantation etc
i've also been able to do webinars for
the veterinary bioscience institute for
this
and on this particular procedure which
really helped in what we're going to
discuss
i've been able to train about 150 people
in these particular procedures
and i put out all that out there because
one would have thought that what was
i was going to discuss was fairly
straightforward
as you can imagine it has been a little
bit less than straightforward for the
past
four months i'm also just as an overview
the procedures that we're talking about
what we're doing is we're injecting into
the csf
filled chamber in the brain there are
two of them
two lateral ventricles left and right
that go in to a central canal
the reason that we're doing this work is
many of the compounds
that work on the central nervous system
will not cross the blood-brain barrier
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
discussing that
but understand it limits both the size
and the type of materials that you can
give
as a dosage anywhere in the body so for
instance the classic taking a pill
um or getting a shot many of those
compounds will not cross
over into the brain which is a constant
problem with
central nervous system compounds
for us it can cost
a tremendous amount of time effort and
money
in a pharmaceutical or a biotech company
to engineer your molecule to cross the
blood-brain barrier
and before you spend all of those
resources you'd probably like to know if
it's actually going to work if it gets
there
and that's why we have this particular
model um
what it allows the various companies to
do
is they can kill off a compound early in
the development cycle because it's not
going to do what they were hoping
before they spend hundreds to thousands
of hours millions to tens of millions of
dollars
months to years of time figuring out how
to get this to get into the brain
in this case we're injecting test
articles such as small molecules gene
therapy vectors asos etc
directly into the cerebral spinal fluid
in the brain
we use the lateral ventricles because
they're the largest area
as you'll see in a little bit that's all
relative
the csf then braids the
bathes the entire brain in the csf
which allows the compound to be
distributed throughout the entire brain
what makes this rather uniquely
difficult as a surgical procedure
is you're effectively working blind
you're injecting
into an area of the body that
you can't see where you certainly can't
see it unless you're going to do a
tremendous amount
of operation and
potentially causing tremendous amount of
trauma
we can't see the area that we're going
to be
ultimately injecting in
so what we need to do is we use
landmarks in this case bregma which is
the intersection of two sutures on top
of the skull
and then an atlas which is designed to
tell you
in three dimensions where do you go from
that particular point
to find the spot that you're trying to
access
and as you can imagine properly
identifying bregma
is incredibly important especially when
you're aiming for a target
that is a tenth of a millimeter or
smaller
this is what it looks like in a live
mouse
plenty of undulations it is not nearly
as
easy to discern where the intersection
actually is as it appears in a nice line
drawing
these are indications of where we are
generally targeting
the black spaces on the right are those
lateral ventricles and you can see
in a euthanized animal where we've done
a dye injection
on the upper left you can see the dye in
the lateral ventricles
and then the lighter shading in the
picture below
is the csf area itself
and what makes this uniquely challenging
is targeting if you were to pull a
credit card or a debit card out of your
wallet
we're aiming for a target that is
approximately one-half to one-third
the depth of your card so turn it on end
look at it
we wish it were that large so
it's not necessarily the most
technically challenging
of procedures but it is very very
precise
and then finally to add a little bit of
a challenge
different strains of animals have
different head shapes
the atlases that we use are based off a
relatively small
number of animals in one very specific
strain also
males not females and there are
differences between the two
so there are a lot of things that we
have to do to make sure that in that
particular strain
of that particular group at that
particular age
that we're actually hitting what we want
to hit and i have other
ones out there on that so i'm not going
to spend a lot of time on that
because here's the point we met with a
client
at the tail end of last year a large
pharmaceutical
and they wanted us to develop this
resource in-house
running approximately one study per week
and so we had an original plan
somewhat aggressive but doable we were
going to obtain the equipment in january
and february
in march we were going to run a pilot
study
and start generating individual studies
for our clients
by april and may we would be bringing
the apprentice surgeons
so that we would have some depth to the
capability
may june we would be validating them and
all of this
until approximately february to march of
this year
seemed like a fairly straightforward
thing we've all in this industry done
this multiple times
but of course there was one minor
unexpected challenge
and that forced a lot of changes to us
and what i'd like to spend the bulk of
this time
discussing is what are the things that
came up
what were the things that we expected
and how are we able to overcome these
challenges
so that all of us as this pandemic
continues
affecting us how are we ready for the
next
unexpected obstacle if you will
and the challenges were many there were
challenges to staffing there were
challenges to supply chains
this requires very specialized equipment
with a handful of manufacturers
most of them seem to be based in either
new york state or california which of
course very aggressively closed down
we also run
anywhere from dozens to
over a hundred studies concurrently
within my group
and the exact same challenges were
hitting every single study
every single sponsor and client that we
had were dealing with the same things as
well so there were ripple effects that
affected us in here
communication face-to-face meetings went
away
the ability to sit in a meeting room
with the various stakeholders
disappeared
and measuring success or failure again
everything was distributed it made many
of our normal functions
remarkably more difficult
we were successful not to give you a
spoiler
here's why and this is really important
you need a solid foundation
that can roll with the various punches
that you're going to have
i have a very motivated and capable
technical staff i have outstanding
supervisors
i have a great management tree without
that
none of this would have been successful
because this was vastly harder
for my technicians and supervisors than
we would have expected
knowing the procedure helped and so the
fact that
i and a few others had a significant
amount of experience
really really helped because we were
able
because we understood the nuances and
the depths of the procedure
we were able to problem solve in a way
that had we been new to this
we probably would not have been able to
again i mentioned upper management
you need their support i had it if we
hadn't
i would have a very very different talk
for today
it would probably be mostly along the
lines of what not to do
during a pandemic
we needed resources beyond my group um
we have an outstanding study director
and nick jones we have
the people around us who were able to
contribute scientific
necropsy all kinds of
affiliated groups that were also all
dealing
with the same things and they had solid
and they had to be able to roll with
these punches as well
we're going to talk a lot about
relationships our vendors
saved us had we
not had vendors who were going to go
above and beyond
we wear surgical masks you all may
recall that back in march and april it
was remarkably hard to get those
lab coats disposable surgical gloves
sterile supplies suture
all of those things became much harder
to find and we were fortunate to have
vendors
who were able to anticipate
substitute work with us wouldn't have
been able to do it without them
and you need a communication
infrastructure you know we talk about
zoom or skype or team site or what have
you
all of those have to be in place
beforehand you have to be used to
working with them
because again if these hadn't been
in place we would have been in deep
trouble trying to develop them while
also dealing with all the other
difficulties
and this is going to keep coming at us
in waves
so we're taking the lessons that we've
learned we're moving on so we do
better and better the next time but we
also know that we're going to be testing
all of these functions
probably fairly frequently for some time
to come
so this is my personal favorite i've
been on several disaster planning
committees
over the years and what seems to be
fairly consistent is the disaster plan
is the thing that you spend a lot of
time in conference rooms discussing
you come up with a whole series of
suggestions
and an implementation strategy that's
going to take a significant amount of
work
that's going to take a significant
amount of money stockpiling supplies
ppe etc and in my experience what
usually
happens is you do a very watered down
version of it
because of course never have to actually
roll our disaster plan
of course we did again very fortunate
in that within the company that i am at
within
the site that i am at we did have a
disaster plan
we did follow it we were as ready as we
could be
um and one of the things i put out there
is
your disaster plan not only do you need
one it has to be something that you can
follow
you can come up with a fantastic
disaster plan i've certainly worked on
committees that have came up
with outstanding disaster plans that
were far too ambitious to follow
so we didn't do anything um it's much
better to have one
that is let's say a seven out of ten but
you're actually going to do it
than one that is a 10 out of 10 that
you're not going to
and again it has to be ready in advance
we had alternate suppliers identified
we had triggers for extra procurement we
had already started cross-training
and identifying personnel resources
throughout the site throughout the
company
in case we had to cover for people who
were no longer going to be on site for a
certain period of time
and we also had a prioritization scheme
so what do you do if
you simply can't stretch that blanket
far enough to cover
everything how do you maximize
your resources to get the critical work
done
and affect the on going
because we're responsible to our clients
they contracted with us we owe them
so how do we minimize the impact on them
when we're going through this as well
which again goes back to the scientific
expertise
that's a decision that has to be made
with several people providing input
and if you don't have them available
you're going to have a difficult time
it's people ultimately at the end of the
day
everything that we do to deal with this
revolves around people
there are employees there are the other
critical groups in-house
there are clients they're our suppliers
they're the local authorities because
you may need a nice letter that says
that you're essential personnel so that
you can go back and forth to work
we had those and as
i'm emphasizing and i can't emphasize it
enough
this is based on the relationships that
you have already established and if you
don't have them yet
you're never going to have a better time
than today to start
you need those in place you cannot be
reaching out to people who don't know
you
and asking them to assist you because
they're getting asked by
heaven knows how many people and if
those people
have developed that type of a personal
relationship
human beings are human beings who are
they going to help
first
so again you can change a relationship
but it's really really
hard when everything is going south and
everyone is under tremendous stress and
everyone is under tremendous stress
i bring up the people in my department
who again they're wonderful
but part of the reason that we were able
to weather this
is before this happened we pushed
responsibility
and decision making authority down the
organizational chart as much as we could
we gave them the training we were
initiative
and we gave them the authority to make
their own best decisions
you can't have a choke point and
certainly the larger the group you have
you can have a very top-down management
style that'll work
when times are normal when things are
constantly up in the air
and you as the leadership is getting
pulled
in a whole series of different
directions you never anticipated
if everyone is dependent upon you or a
very small group of people to make every
single decision
you will fail and i've watched it happen
before
i've watched it happen during this
pandemic um
and one of the pieces is not just you
trust them
do they trust you do they believe
and understand and do they have evidence
that
you're going to give them that ability
to make those decisions
and you're going to protect them because
we do make bad decisions i make bad
decisions
everybody does do they know that they
are
going to make the best decision possible
or is it a risk for them
because if it's a risk people being
people they will default back
to i'm going to ask first and if you get
hit with 100 questions a minute
you cannot answer all of them so you
need that type of initiative
we had it thank heavens
and everything is interconnected and you
have to trust them so again you have to
build those relationships back and forth
we have the people who take care of our
animals
had they fallen we would have been done
necropsy clintpath our study directors
purchasing
client services legal it goes on and on
and on and if any one of those groups
had dropped the ball
because we're interconnected we might
not have failed
although i suspect we probably would
have but it would have been immeasurably
harder
and also all of our people are dealing
with outside stress
um many of us myself included have lost
friends and loved ones during this
people at work or their
close relations could develop the virus
people could get seriously ill
people could get worse than that
there's the uncertainty have i been
exposed have i not when we couldn't get
tests
etc especially in the early days when
testing was difficult to obtain
and certainly much of my staff is
relatively young
they were not a priority for testing
back when test kits were difficult to
obtain their loved ones
have anxiety um especially when
as with all of us who have worked
through this if you're essential
personnel
then everyone around you who is not is
worried about you going out
interacting with other people what are
you opposed to
the schools are closed we had to make
numerous accommodations because
people didn't have schools or child care
for their children anymore
so flexible scheduling became very
important there were no extracurricular
activities
and people need things to do
to regather their emotional energy
all those were shut down people weren't
going to the gym they weren't going out
with friends
and so the stress just built and of
course there's an anxiety being in
public
i mean most of us can remember this as
we were driving back and forth
it was spooky being out on the roads
especially in march and april because
you were alone
and our clients are going through the
same thing everybody
that we're interacting with is going
through these same things
and so constant last-minute schedule
changes requests
you know we stayed open during this
because as our various clients and
universities
had to pull back their operations we
were the ones who were able to keep
things moving along
in all of these various areas of school
research
but all of those rippled into these
studies as well
so if i have one message in all of this
it is
take care of your people and i'll add to
it
you can't start taking care of your
people
when the disaster hits you have to have
a culture where they
know that you are looking out for them
and that you will do the right ethical
thing
for them whether you necessarily have to
or not
you have to be compassionate and yes
the structures and the expectations and
the accountability
are at least as important as they were
before because people need
structure they need to understand what
the rules and the requirements are and
if you throw all of that up
it's very difficult to work when you
don't know what the expectations are
and what we found is that having that
type of structure was actually a stress
relievers
everything is going unstructured in
people's lives
having an area where there actually is
structure
there's accountability trees and what
have you
was actually remarkably distressing it
was relaxing
in a rather odd way um we did a lot of
what i call wargaming and planning
you never make a decision as well
when everything is going sideways as you
would have when the stress is not there
and the pressure is not there and the
time constraints aren't there
and i'm very much an advocate of work
your content
work your contingency plans before
things hit the wall in my group
my supervisors came to me with a great
idea let's meet every morning at eight
o'clock let's triage do we have people
out what's the work
what are the changes that we're getting
from our clients and so on
um we ran that through may
and again this requires that dedication
and flexibility from our technicians
if i had poor technicians none of this
would have worked but i didn't
had outstanding technicians who rose to
the challenge
as an aside what was fascinating is
our efficiency and
our quality metrics
just improved dramatically over the
course of this which again
shows when people are rising to the
challenge
a whole bunch of things are just taken
in stride
but we did we were aggressive we
immediately implemented social
distancing we
broke up we have a large technician area
we broke that up we moved people around
so that we weren't sitting close
together
wherever possible we had people working
remotely we
moved our meetings to skype and team
site and we did that very very quickly
and we closed our circle we did not
bring outside visitors to sites we
didn't bring clients we didn't bring
vendors
we kept ourselves to ourselves and
whenever
and we've had uh people test positive
we have had people who didn't test
positive but required testing because of
symptoms we moved aggressively
we moved people into self quarantine we
emphasized testing we try to break
the if you will circle of people being
able to
to communicate the virus to others we
were very aggressive
and knock on wood it has stood us in
good stead to date and what this all
meant because of that flexibility
because of people willing to do things
that maybe weren't part of their
standard job
but if there's a need the study comes
first we're going to get it done and
people pitching in
our impacts have been fairly minimal
even when we've had staff
out due to either suspected infections
or actual infections
but i put this in here because we
weren't flawless not by any stretch
um and it's the little things and we
knew this beforehand
but there were things that we didn't
think of and one of the things that we
didn't think of
is we did a wonderful job preparing for
our
formal suppliers but the things that you
get at the grocery store
who would have thought that we would
have empty shelves i mean to date
whenever we've had
either an outbreak such as the avian flu
or disasters those are
fairly rapid they're not nation or
certainly worldwide
but so we uh use clear drape and we
actually use
press and seal which we ethylene oxide
sterilize
as one of our common drapes both because
it's transparent
so we can more easily monitor our
patient but it also has
a very very low tack adhesive and on
mice whose skin is very thin we don't
want to irritate it
and a lot of adhesive drapes the
adhesive is fairly aggressive because
they're designed for humans
they will cause issues for the animals
this is
much more humane and
relatively innocuous to our patients
and i'll just throw out there call it an
aside
um regardless of the species
asepsis so eliminating microorganisms
from your sterile field
analgesics ie pain control they are
important in every single species
and we treat all of our species the same
way
for this though it's present seal you
can
go and buy it at the supermarket
until you can't and all of a sudden for
several weeks
press and seal disappeared along with so
many other things from the store shelves
never considered that never occurred to
me that
we would have that type of disruption to
our commercial supply chains
we were fortunate i got some people in
my group i have a management tree we
went to all of them and said if you're
at the store and you see this stuff just
buy it
and they did and we were able to get
enough to carry us through and now that
it's back on the shelves
um we have stockpiled it so if anything
hits in the future we will be ready
and there are other examples but i put
this out there
look at your entire supply chain look at
every
single thing that you need to do your
work
what this taught me is you can't make
the assumption
consciously or unconsciously that there
are things you don't have to worry about
there are things that i didn't think we
had to worry about and we did
positive relationships with our vendors
are critical again we depended upon them
to go the extra mile
had we spent all of our time yelling at
them
had we spent all of our time every
instance
of a delay beating them down
would they have been as
frankly wonderful as they were they
might have been
but they might not have been and that's
not a risk that i'm really want to take
and certainly i'm glad that we didn't
take
and i put this in here because i think
they do deserve a call out
um our stereotax devices came from david
koff
who in the midst of a shutdown they were
still figuring out ways to get me
materials world precision instruments
uh george tamman is another one that
they were shutting down but they still
figured out a way to get us the stuff
that we needed
uh mine viewer for our pp and disposable
supplies
um there was a lot of creativity from
people
um in our animal care unit who were
taking care of that piece were jumping
through hoops to make sure that that
stuff arrived when we needed it
again had we had a bad relationship
with them beforehand we would not have
been able to reset that during all of
this
and it might have gone really really
badly for us
understanding the equipment um and
really understanding the equipment
the example that i'll use is what
happens
if the people who show up to repair your
equipment
suddenly can't can you continue
functioning
or are the things that you plug into a
wall socket
these magical boxes that someone will
come and fix
or calibrate but you don't know how they
work you don't know how to troubleshoot
them because of course you can always
call in a repair
person will be there within 24 hours
until they can't be
again you can't wait until the disaster
hits you have to be ready in advance you
have to do your due diligence and really
understand
what do we know we were fortunate
again david kopf was
that company was jumping through hoops
to get us things but there were still
delays
and our sponsor provided us some
stereotax devices
they were damaged in shipment
we had to fix them and normally what you
would do is you would send them back to
the vendor and they would repair them
but they couldn't
what is very fortunate is back in the
early 90s
i was able to attend a wonderful
three-day class on how to fix
and repair these particular pieces of
equipment and i'm kind of a nerd in that
area anyways
but it's always stuck with me how useful
it is in the middle of
for instance the study i don't have to
cancel things and wait two weeks
i can fix and repair in this case i was
able to recalibrate the units i was able
to use
wonderful laser grid um
piece of equipment to reset everything
in that enabled us to continue
if we hadn't been able to i would have
had to ship them back for refurbishment
i would still be waiting for them
because the place and the engineers that
would have fixed them
have been shut down again
it's too late to get the training when
the virus is hit you need to do that
ahead of time
and i emphasize we know that we're going
to experience
waves of effects over the next few
months
years we don't know so if you're not
ready now
there's no time like the present to
start getting that information things
are starting to loosen up a bit
now is the time to identify those gaps
and get them filled
because maybe we'll be lucky and we
won't have to go through another cycle
of this but if we do
we had best be ready
and the short version is as i said my
spoiler we were successful
um we've run we're actually over 11 but
when i wrote this we're at 11
studies with lateral ventricles
hippocampal injections and fecal
injections as well
we're now over 500 surgeries since march
we've been able to train 12 technicians
on the various support roles
in addition four surgeons apprentice
surgeons are validating they started
validating last week and they continue
today
as a matter of fact with another five to
go
we're running one or two of these
studies weekly um
we were successful and it was because of
our people
and it was because of our pre-planning
so ultimately what did i learn from this
you have to have the right people they
have to be dedicated they have to be
willing to roll with things this was a
very stressful time
and people could have been forgiven for
not being able to roll with the
metaphoric punches but they did
they needed to be trained and if we
hadn't spent the time training
and i can't take the credit for that
that's my training arm
that's my supervisors those are my team
leads who spent the time with
technicians and trained them
and then we have trained those people
they're independent
and they're empowered and we didn't
become independent and empowered when we
didn't have the bandwidth
to oversee them they were already there
before
all of this hit you've got to have the
positive functional relationships with
the various key stakeholders and
impactors it's too late to develop them
when everything is going sideways
you've got to have expertise in all of
the areas
and i could talk at great length about
all the various people who brought their
specialized experience and knowledge to
the
boot for this we had prior planning
not just the specific disaster plans but
we had redundancies and contingency
plans
just ready just in case
and we also had structures that enabled
quality from
all of our people when they were under
tremendous stress they have been
and they continue to be and stress is
debilitating over time
one of the things that my supervisors
did
is they looked for opportunities to have
appropriately social distance but events
nonetheless
to have some fun and to relieve the
stress
and to look out for people hey you know
what
why don't you work from home tomorrow
you have things coming up
again had i not had that type of an
atmosphere
and that type of a culture it would have
been too late to create it
but again my supervisors did a wonderful
job
minimizing the stress and taking care of
the people who work for them
it all comes down to you have to be
prepared you have to be ready you have
to be ready before the crisis hits
it's too bloody late to try and put all
of these things into place
after everything has gone sideways
and with that there's a picture of my
current icv
team and if you have any questions i
would be happy to answer them